ces immeubles du gouvernement fédéral
sont pratiquement vides depuis des mois
des tours à bureaux au télétravail
la pandémie a bouleversé le quotidien
des fonctionnaires la pandémie famille
la loupe sur plein de bobos
chantal fortin représentante syndicale à
l'alliance de la fonction publique du
canada
depuis des mois elle reçoit de plus en
plus de témoignages au sujet du recul du
bilinguisme
ils ont que le français ce que j'entends
c'était comme peut-être une deuxième
pensée mais avec la pandémie que tout
est fait virtuelle on dirait qu'une
troisième penser des vidéoconférences
uniquement en anglais des documents qui
ne sont pas traduits et un rythme
effréné qui laisse plus de place pour le
français
ça crée de la frustration parce que j'ai
pas autant d'aisance en anglais qu'en
français donc je me perds dans le flot
d'informations en anglais on l'appellera
rémy pour protéger son identité
il est l'un de ceux qui subit les
contrecoups de la pandémie
quand les gens parlent et qu'on comprend
pas la moitié de ce qu'ils disent qu'il
ya des coupures aussi un moment donné on
se concentre plus un professeur de
l'université de moncton s'est penché sur
la question linguistique dans la
fonction publique fédérale
les défis auxquels font face les
francophones sont désormais amplifié
selon lui je pense que ça met en lumière
un problème d'ordre structurel qui est
là depuis toujours
ottawa l'opposition fustige le
gouvernement
c'est inacceptable que les nos langues
officielles subissent les contrecoups de
la pandémie la pandémie n'est pas une
excuse moi je me dis quand on a un gage
quelqu'un c'est pas parce qu'une
pandémie que les droits des francophones
doivent être envoyées dans le caniveau
le gouvernement admet que la pandémie a
bouleversé la vie de bien des gens si le
ministre se dit conscient du problème
il veut des changements on est conscient
que c'est pas toujours faim peut pas
toujours facile de le faire mais c'est
important de le faire après notre appel
de la semaine dernière le ministre
duclos dit avoir écrit une lettre à ses
collègues ministres pour que le droit de
bien communiquer en français soit
réaffirmée au sein des ministères
reste à voir si la demande sera
respectée il c'est antoine trépanier
radio canada ottawa